it's officially week six of google cloud
next on air
which means we're focusing on data
management and databases
i'm jen person and welcome to this week
in cloud where we're taking a sneak peek
at this week's content week six is all
about
data management and databases meaning
we're highlighting how google's cloud
databases
are simple to use without compromising
on security
reliability or open standards we've got
sessions on data migration stories
modernization advice
and integrating everything from your
cassandra workloads
to your existing sql server so be sure
to check out the session catalog
and don't forget to explore the demos to
see what you can do
no matter what your data solution looks
like it needs to be reliable
you need to be confident your database
service can recover from user errors
infrastructure failures and full region
outages
that's why we're shining this week's
spotlight on high availability
and disaster recovery with cloud sql
this talk is packed full of advice and
insight
on how cloud sql leverages replication
and automatic health checks
to keep your database online
one session on my own playlist is how to
choose the right database because
there are quite a few options out there
and the right one for you
depends on what you're trying to do this
talk will walk you through the strengths
of various google cloud databases
from the perspective of different use
cases from lift and shift
to modernization of existing
applications and net new development
this talk covers it all of course
effective data management is about more
than storing and querying your data
those are just the foundation building
systems that offer
insights to empower your business this
video demos
offers an example of this by showing one
retailer can use
cloud spanner to build a real-time
inventory management system
to support their online sales to add
these sessions to your digital playlist
check out the link any ideas or thoughts
leave us a comment or tweet us using the
hashtag
google cloudnext we'll see you in the
cloud